robin salut tout le monde comme vous
savez je fais partie du comité
organisateur de cette soirée est une de
mes tâches et a décidé de s'y essayer de
trouver des conférenciers en faisant ça
il ya plusieurs personnes qui m'ont
répondu la même phrase
cette phrase laisse une phrase que
j'utilisais beaucoup avant la france
j'aimerais sûr mais j'ai pas le temps
j'ai pas le temps vous connaissez
sûrement des gens qui ont jamais le
temps de rien faire
peut-être même que c'est vous qui avez
jamais le temps le manque de tintin
excuses à plusieurs situations on
utilise cette phrase le canton dit me
ton j'aimerais souhaiter aider mais j'ai
pas le temps ou au bois j'aimerais ça
est en forme mais j'ai vraiment pas le
temps d'aller m'entraîner mais la
meilleure que j'ai entendu c'est
probablement celle là moi j'aimerais
tellement sale en vacances mais j'ai pas
le temps on dirait que le manque de
temps est devenue la maladie du siècle
mais ce que c'est vraiment de maladie ou
c'est plutôt les symptômes qui cacherait
autre chose on le sait bien
le temps est le même pour tout le monde
une journée contre 24 heures une semaine
168 heures pour une heure de plus point
noir de moins est ce que vous soyez
riche pauvre jeune ou vieux si vous
faites partie de la moyenne des gens
vous travaillez environ 40 heures par
semaine et vous devez endormir environ
donc en théorie il vous reste soixante
huitard vous n'avez rien à faire
bon là il y en a qui vont me dire oui
mais fou je m'occupe des enfants où il
faut que je fasse le super excitée
recruter un bon admettons toutes vos
tâches sont offertes qui vous reste en
gros 20 heures par semaine
qu'est ce que vous allez faire de ces 20
heures le vous allez rester assis devant
télé puis regardez le temps passe et il
ya un autre chose qui me dérange un peu
c'est le fait que la france j'ai pas le
temps est tout le temps suivi d'un parce
que ou d'un à cause d'eux mais pourquoi
peut-être qu'on sent coupable qu'on a
besoin de se justifier la france j'ai
pas le temps sert aussi des excuses pour
se faire pardonner
mais surtout ça sert à nous convaincre
nous mêmes qu'on avait une bonne raison
de pas faire ce qu'on aurait dû faire
le ch pourrait faire comme les
spécialistes en gestion du temps pressé
de donner des techniques pour mieux vous
gérez votre teint lui est organisé mais
non je ferais pas ça parce que je pense
pas que le manque de temps c'est le vrai
problème quand j'ai décidé le sujet dont
j'allais vous parlez je me suis mis à
regarder les gens autour de moi plus
précisément ceux qui ont toujours leur a
manqué de temps ceux qui disent tout le
temps qu'ils ont beau temps je me suis
rendu compte que quand on utilise cette
phrase le sait quand ils sont dans une
situation inconfortable le manque de
temps leur sert d' excuses
c'est une excuse qui cache quoi ça cache
sûrement quelque chose ça maintenant
poser une question suivante et si la
france j'ai paul temps ça représentait
pas vraiment un problème de temps ou
d'organisation mais plutôt un problème
de détermination ou encore de port
admettons qu à chaque fois qu'on veut
dire j'ai pas le temps on essayait de
remplacer le moteur par un autre mot je
pense que dans plusieurs cours on
pourrait le remplacer par le mot courage
ou encore par le mot détermination donc
on manquerait de courage et oman écrite
détermination mais pour faire quoi au
juste
c'est facile pour sortir de notre zone
de confort le jeu pourrait vous donner
une définition d'un scientifique de la
zone de confort ma place de tous j'ai
décidé de demander à un de mes petits
gars samuel que le vin pour lui c'est
quoi la zone de confort salut salut et
c'est quoi pour toi la zone de confort
non je vous exhorte à tous les jours et
je bois c'est bien après tout des jeunes
pilotes brevetés la vendée
et tu veux sortir de sa zone de confort
un autre exemple etc sont là nous suit
défense assez ghinzu ils m'ont fait
jouer à la faculty peu j'ai sorti de ma
zone de confort ça fait quoi quand aso
cité zone de confort le il fait plus
dans saison de comptage et pose une
question qui n'était pas prévu donc la
fameuse on de confort on en entend
souvent parler mais c'est quoi au juste
c'est une zone où on est bien où on s'en
vient où on se croit à l'abri des échecs
des erreurs de tout ce qui pourrait mal
aller se nomme dans laquelle on fait
juste les choses dans lesquelles on a de
l'expérience
les choses qu'on est bon dans cette zone
là rien d'extraordinaire exposé via pas
vraiment défi tout ce qu'on fait on le
fait par automatisme
on est dans ses bonnes vieilles
pantoufles comme on dit ici rassurer la
question qu'il faut se poser c'est
est-ce que c'est bon de rester dans sa
zone de confort moi je pense que non
parce que quand on reste dans cette zone
là on développe des peurs notamment
notre confiance en soi diminue rester
dans la zone de confort
c'est resté dans un chemin facile c'est
difficile de sortir de la zone de
confort parce qu'on a peur de changer
nos petites habitudes
l'être humain à part de l'inconnu et
c'est bien normal mais pourquoi qu'on
voudrait sortir de la zone de confort
bien aller vers une zone puisque du
temps j'ai une question qu'on peut se
poser si c'est quand la dernière fois
que vous avez fait quelque chose pour la
première fois pensez-y essayer d'y
répondre
sortir de sa zone de confort puis faire
des choses pour la première fois ça va
vous amener à grandir
vous allez évoluer vous allez explorer
vous allez découvrir des côtés devant de
votre personnalité que vous connaissez
pas vous allez vous découvrir des forces
d'état l'un des nouveaux talents avec
soin votre confiance en vous vaugh
mentez
avez vous déjà pensé à tout ce que vous
n'aviez pas fait parce que vous aviez
peur à toutes les belles opportunités
vous avez manqué je pense que vous êtes
passé à côté de bien belles choses
la taille même que vous avez des regrets
en ce qui me concerne si j'avais pas
réussi à surmonter ma peur je serais pas
ici ce soir
non parce que parler devant du monde
pour moi c'est une grande peur j'aime
pas ce jeu ici même
donc c'est vraiment un grand défi
maintenant si on schématise et notre
environnement notre vie au milieu ça
pourrait ressembler au million dans la
zone de confort comme je parle depuis
tantôt tout et confortable tout est
rassurant un peu à l'extérieur on a
maison qui s'appelle la zone
d'apprentissage dans cette zone là il se
trouve des choses qu'on ai jamais fait
mais sont un petit peu d'effort un petit
peu d'énergie
on veut capable de réussir à l'extérieur
complètement
c'est là que le fonds ne commence son
dos dial évidemment ça s'appelle la zone
de magie mais les plus pessimistes aime
bien l'appeler la zone de panique mais
motta soit on est optimiste on va
l'appeler la zone de magie c'est quoi la
zone de magic johnson qui comprend
toutes les choses qu'on n'a jamais fait
les choses qui nous font peur les choses
qu'on pense qu'ils sont est possible à
faire
pis même un peu stupide c'est une zone
qui comprend des opportunités des
expériences incroyables mais
principalement si la zone où se situe la
passion et les rohff
parce que oui si on veut réaliser ses
plus grands rêves on n'a pas le choix de
passer par la zone de magie mais le faut
je vous avertis quand on décide d'aller
dans un monde de magie on a une montée
d'adrénaline incroyable je vous le dis
si vous l'essayez vous allez vraiment
aimé ça mais malheureusement c'est pas
n'importe qui qui peut aller dans un
monde de magie
qu'est ce que vous pensez que ça prend
pour aller dans cette zone là
premièrement fall et ses côtés ses peurs
ses craintes
son manque de confiance en soi et toutes
les défaites inimaginable comme le gpo
le temps dont je vous parlais tantôt
faut être t'accepte un certain malaise
perdre ses moyens ses repères pendant
quelques temps faut surtout su trouver
la motivation
sa motivation peu importe c'est quoi il
faut la trouver
c'est difficile d'aller dans cette zone
là parce qu'on sait ce qu'on va perdre
non c'est parce qu'on va gagner
on sait qu'on va avoir peur on sait
qu'on va avoir mal on sait qu'on va
sûrement se décourager qu'on va vouloir
abandonner
on sait pas ce que ça va donner au bout
de la ligne c'est ce qui était pas pour
aller dans un monde de magie faut être
prêt à prendre des risques mais surtout
faut arrêter d'écouter la petite voix
telle est voit dans notre taille qui
nous dit tout le temps fait parce ça
marche repos fait passer tout votre
plante et ou pire encore fait pas ce
sera jamais capable pour y entrer pas
besoin de faire de grandes choses
rappelez vous quand vous étiez petit la
première fois que vous avez conduit
votre vélo à 100 les petites roues ou
encore à l'adolescence quand vous avez
rencontré votre premier tome votre
première blonde la première fois que
vous l'avez abordé
vous étiez dans votre zone de magie il
faut faire des petites choses simples
écoutez un nouveau style de musique
faire un nouveau sport et le nouvel an
en fait faut faire quelque chose qu'on
n'est jamais fini
mais qu'est ce que ça donne d'aller dans
cette zone le ca va faire que vous allez
croire en vous vous allez devenir sûr de
vous vos limites vont être toujours de
plus en plus loin vos barrières de plus
en plus hot wheels ainsi votre zone de
confort va s'agrandir de plus amples
salle et découvrir de nouvelles choses
des nouvelles sensations vous allez
avoir le sentiment d'accomplir quelque
chose de vous êtes dépassé le plus
important vous allez réussir à réaliser
vos rêves
même les plus fous et croyez-moi quand
qu'on atteint un but qu'on s'était fixés
on est tellement fier que tout d'un coup
on se dit waouh
finalement c'était pire j'ai eu pas pour
rien puis on a le goût de recommencer
encore et encore finalement mon message
ce soir c'est pour vous dire d'arrêter
dès que vous avez pas le temps quand
quelque chose qui est important pour
nous on trouve toujours le temps aussi
avant de dire que vous n'avez pas le
temps utilisé les bons mots en faisant
ce vous allez vous rendre compte que
c'est pas du temps nous manquer mais
c'est plutôt de courage quand vous aurez
réalisé ce rappelez vous que dans vif
osé faisait sauter il faut oser prendre
des risques faisait faire des choix
arrêtés de remettre à demain tout ce qui
vous effraient il faut toujours choisir
l'option qui la plus difficile
que c'est là qu'ils vont nous ouvrir le
plus de portes entourez vous de gens qui
vont vous c'est qu'ils vont vite
challenger on peut toujours faire plus
qu est ce qu on croit pouvoir
si vous voulez vraiment quelque chose
allait chercher croyances
j'espère aussi que ce soir je vous ai
démontré que quand on va dans un monde
de magie on en meurt pour la preuve
chants corses vente
j'ai réussi à surmonter ma clope grande
part et pour ceux qui n'ont pas encore
compris l'importance de sortir de sa
zone de confort je vais vous laisser du
temps de penser à tout ça par vous même
à votre rythme
en espérant que vous trouverez le temps
de le faire merci